l'inquiétude règne toujours autour de la
centrale nucléaire de zappos ridja
derniers rebondissements la coupure
totale d'eau et d'électricité à nerfs
godard à proximité de la plus grande
centrale d'europe des frappes au niveau
de la centrale thermique en serait à
l'origine
conséquence les opérations menées par l'
agence internationale de l'énergie
atomique ne sont plus sécurisés une
situation qui a poussé le directeur
général de l' ua a tiré la sonnette
d'alarmé
chalet
des bombardements met en danger les
opérateurs et leurs familles de fait il
devient difficile d'avoir suffisamment
de personnel pour faire fonctionner la
centrale cela a considérablement
augmenté le risque d'accident nucléaire
soyons clairs les bombardements autour
de la centrale nucléaire de zappos ridja
doivent cesser et une zone de sûreté et
de protection de la sécurité nucléaire
doit être convenue immédiatement sur
zone hagrid immediately la sécurité des
employés de la centrale seraient
également mis à mal ce vendredi le
patron de l'opérateur ukrainien de
zappos ridja accuse la russie
d'exactions
selon lui deux personnes aurait été
battu à mort par les soldats russes
costaud mais
aujourd'hui la situation est très
difficile car il ya des tortures des
passages à tabac des enlèvements de
personnels en bourse
environ 200 membres du personnel de la
centrale ont été capturés deux personnes
ont été battues amand
[Musique]
les eaux à dispose de deux observateurs
sur place et propose de créer une zone
de sécurité sur le site mais kiev
souhaite plutôt une mission
internationale de maintien de la paix
occupée par les russes depuis le mois de
mars la centrale de zappos ridja est
régulièrement visée par des
bombardements dont kiev et moscou se
rejettent la responsabilité